I can see photos because to me I just
seem surprised
no I honestly because when I see him I
just see an old white dude oh man you
gotta look deeper than that dude I'll go
behind the eye surface like I know that
he's a draft dodger that's all I know
Oh is he really I told you that oh yeah
I could see that he's an active hippie
oh yeah he wanted a party instead of
fight yeah some people want a gun and
some people wanted the pipe that's what
I heard anyway it was like the Dodgers
really wanted to party you and I you're
a pop guy or fight guy back then I'd
probably load my gun with a couple grams
and just shoot him right at my [ __ ]
nose Bubba somewhere in the middle yeah
whenever I see like movies on Woodstock
or anything like that
I just know I would died yeah just the
way I did it even without like outside I
did it in a different era yeah drugs and
alcohol and I did it so hard that I
could I'd probably be just be dead
underneath Jim Morrison's dead body in a
bathtub you know there was an Asian guy
I don't know man he was just there a
bike trying to sell a bicycle yeah yeah
what a [ __ ] crazy guy yeah I would at
that era I would have been just [ __ ]
a load else with the kind of pure drugs
that they had back then like I'm pretty
sure it might mean that the weed the
weed is probably stronger now
oh yeah we had that Brown frown that's
all we summer right right around Friday
yeah yeah but back then they had drugs
that the PCP I mean there's drugs that
yeah yeah crazy oh they have PCP a all
kind of [ __ ] angel dust I don't even
know what that's will you get that PVC
there peoples [ __ ] smoking you know I
long pieces of plastic
[Music]
I'm Evie pee when I was in high school
we'd [ __ ] burn anything it would
[ __ ] burn and burn in a pipe in
[ __ ] smoke if you could I mean I mean
in a different lifetime if there was a
drug that you could try then one of the
newer ones like Flocka or spice would
you try it crack I would do crack oh
yeah I never got to smoke crack and
I feel like I wish I would have yeah I
see how one can probably want to get
into yeah dude my ship was always hiding
behind something yeah there was no wood
nothing to run out [ __ ] go yeah I
think I could see us two in a burnout
building like doing that oh it's way too
much for me yeah what if you need your
buddy oh but if he has a [ __ ]
directions to somewhere you guys do a
couple you know you come you [ __ ] ate
half of your buddy
yeah you're thinking I can't get to
Baker I'm never gonna be able to find my
iPod yeah guys [ __ ] Lawrence knew
where it was
yeah and now he bled out you know cuz
you can't say into somebody eating half
of his [ __ ] arm yeah but you how much
sobriety do you have now I got probably
two and a half years just like this
thing whatever yeah but two and a half
years ago you could dad crack back then
I know I just forgot to smoke him for
you alright yeah yeah there's a lot of
that yeah that's funny because I had a
two year window when I relapsed mm-hmm
and that could have done anything I
wanted but ironical I I didn't go to the
ones I desired during the 12 years I had
sober like LSD mushrooms I never did on
any of those I did a couple of times
um ecstasy mhm and then I just drank and
smoked pot and that's it was it fun when
you went out you know in the peak no
well no I took vicodin to so I did you
know sixty vicodins a day but um -
that's what drove me down but fun yeah I
do remember I'm telling right now I have
a [ __ ] computer doesn't work I have a
computer that doesn't work oh wow and I
want to go to a shop to get a fix
because I have videos I know they're on
there of me
can check no no of these that's illegal
of the out of my mind I remember when
the technology came out with cameras and
stuff
I remember taping myself doing drugs and
and I also taped myself during my
vicodin withdrawal so I remember on
screen crying telling myself like The
Bodyguard sounds like the end of The
Bodyguard you seen that movie you met
the show so good this is so good so good
about Whitney Houston no he watched Game
of Thrones it's a guy who plays Robb
Stark it's about a guy coming back from
the from Afghanistan yes PTSD and now he
has to be the the private bodyguard to a
high high-ranking politician who has
opposing views as him steal the name of
the bodyguard is when Kevin Costner
jumps in front of a bull Whitney Houston
doesn't get hit by it even though years
later she doesn't much she overdoses in
her bathtub it's not there oh yeah where
was he then yeah